[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
or we talked about one so we don't want
to get too monetized but all anyone is
talking about is the thing that you
think diverse so I have an idea you know
how like sometimes it when you say David
like it's like dovey
well what if we pronounced it co-lead so
you know it's like the you know Verrilli
right now wow you put it in a dress for
me I thought that word isn't demonetized
anymore that they brought it back well
it depends like they're deeming people
worthy of being able to use it really
Kumiko avocado use it because then I'll
use nikko kado that's an absurd sounding
person saying an absurd thing has been
effective I'm so bored
he'd I've been hold on but didn't say
that word around
wait why because you can't tell me that
you have nothing to do I'll give you
something to do so [ __ ] is cook you
should be cleaned I've been doing that
aren't you cleaning speed your [ __ ]
closet is disgusting clean your closet
goddamn you disgusting person
this board is like tell my mama more has
never been cleaner but me and my family
have squared up like three different
sizes up like like like let's go out in
the middle street let's go ahead and
let's with all three was me my wife a
lord what always like it's just like
like but the house has never been having
baseboards we clean best boys doorknobs
and change the knob man yeah
say you're bored done you could say I
would never say that alone no no because
here's the thing it's not the [ __ ]
1700s where all you have is like a
candle and a in your Grandpa's book and
a [ __ ] rocking horse
it's the Information Age you could
literally learn how to do anything you
want I have so many things I want to do
I'm have enough time in the day I'm so
happy about being stuck indoors all day
yeah but I'm not as boring as you all do
fun [ __ ] go play baseball you [ __ ]
ass yeah what about what I wanna hang
out with people and talk to people
the girls let's do it that'd be so
boring those guys'll team all right no
dying at home cuz what were you saying
alright so Joey's a big big big
extrovert right needs the energy of
people mm-hmm he was telling me like no
matter how long he is on vacation after
he comes back home if he's sitting at
home in silence for like four to six
hours he starts going crazy
yes so I don't know if you guys I don't
know if you guys ever traveled them so
I've done a ton of shows with them right
like if we get off the plane and we
leave like the students that bring us
around or whatever if he's like alone in
this hotel room he just starts stealing
that's how my dad is
oh he just starts going crazy from the
Rings again what the meet and greet goes
longer than two hours you start seeing
four like this you just see my [ __ ]
spell we saw him what it's you know why
we hear so long
wait Lord will come back I will sniff
funerals are pretty boring
they sing too much crazy jmi like I
don't even want people's eyes come up
like this one time we did this but like
nothing longer than a minute then a DJ
goes back he's playing like my favorite
songs from 20 pounds you don't like a
wedding theme funeral or like there's a
cake and like people yeah you cut the
cake there's like a DJ everyone's
dancing there's an open bar yeah my
funerals gonna be lived you said you
went and I was like no I want yeah I
want an annual thing to like like my
birthday like keep it going like
different things I was gonna be like a
Halloween thing can I cut up a somebody
today there's a cup that's that's a wide
overlay for a company but like hey be
remembered it's a memorial to see your
estate so cool then what my estate Oh
Hamlet oh yeah that's it that's so
goddamn sick to say you have an estate I
want an estate we have an estate do you
oh yeah yeah where are our financial
account to set it up cuz like they're
like minute you're getting married about
to have kids you need the next you need
a plan for it there's a big adult where
it's call it fiduciary order it's like
my brain really quick I die or Gio dies
then a who takes care of tyka and you
want to have checks and balances so the
person that takes care of tyka does not
have access to the finances because then
you're like there's people that go like
just know it the weird family member
come all right take care
Tiger next to the money so you want to
have different family men with the hand
always the butler in those movies thanks
I'll take care like I love children
[Laughter]
that's some adult [ __ ] it's really sexy
it is sexy that's pretty boss right
there [ __ ] kids that's what this
shirt literally says it's just a nice
way of saying [ __ ] those kids oh the
first letter and like I see it
them kids I'll commit it to it yeah it's
a lifestyle it's [ __ ] suck the
happiness out of you I was way happier
like this is the [ __ ] front all this
I've actually never seen him happier
really what the key but I also think
it's because he doesn't have to hang out
the kids that much
he's never hanging out he's always like
going on runs first thing in the morning
he got Billy Paul's
he said he was going back to join the
Marines I'm like this dude's our
thoughts on this full-time dad what my
step their responsibility so I'd be that
happy - yeah he's like it's crying it
gos account he cries he goes rap to G
all night yeah I wonder why the he's
like women are just better at handling
[Music]
just so good with kids there's the guys
can't compete yeah because I know that
about your boy that's why this morning I
asked you I was like so how's it been at
home why would I tell you hey do you
really want me to say what you said yeah
that's kind of funny what I say here we
go okay well it's really sweet he really
enjoys spending more time at the juice I
know I'll get there talking about Kobe
I'm Joe like waiting for the [ __ ]
punch
you like it's been really nice it's
seeing the family spending more time
with TECA and all but he's like I have
my strict work hours where I work at the
at the end at the west wing of the house
I didn't say that sounds like Bart no
but that he's like I'm Lots in you know
like you can hear take this footsteps
running down the hallway and GOP like
John disturb Bob but just the fact that
you have still like very set like right
now is my alone time even though you're
at home with your parents not for me I
told you why I had to do it to do your
business man he has to run a lot of
business you think it's funny like
having that with everything else that
they were all saying I just like pair
those things up I do enjoy him around
he's awesome that long time is
essentially like my family we have like
two hours where we break out everybody
go sit at home roll like their
respective corners and don't [ __ ]
talk to me guys dough is like going on a
roll
literally helps me miss my family when I
come home I'm a better person that's
true Yeah right like I'm a natural owner
like I can literally be by myself for
days and don't have to talk to anybody
I'll be on the phone like so like being
with them 24/7 is like I'm either gonna
hate you guys I'll kill you so I have to
get this time alone cuz like cheese my
heart would get mad with you in the
bathroom for like an hour like I can't
see you right now I just got home give
me a second of [ __ ] so I can give you
some good energy if I come in off the
street with Street energy you're not
gonna like me cuz everybody's gonna be a
[ __ ]
I've been seeing these days [ __ ]
families jogging together are you mother
[ __ ]
cuz no one does that [ __ ] that's so
gross no I think that is best parents
best parents trying to wear their kids
out there trying to wear
crazy Your Honor community like all
three of us go as fast as you can I'll
race you put a rub around of kids that
hey man just like Thomas latrine let him
run around to the side of same way you
do a dog you'd be fine
that's a merry-go-round yeah we built
you America right y'all grief a little
[ __ ] I'm gonna have this so clingy like
she's his life in like right here don't
[Music]
I don't like that I had to close my door
and lock my cats out cuz they yeah
there's no that they're good boys
they'll wait there but they're weak
right outside the door like if I open
the door they're both looking up at me
like this this would wait there's a lot
of commitment you to cats or no
commitment literally no commit my
biggest grief with animals is like just
pet hair
I don't like pet hair everywhere kids
animals all of this anything that can't
add to the builds in the house that
they're creating I don't like it
elderly they don't work in like you know
welcome to don't care either way [ __ ]
about it some Campbell's in the kitchen
go heat it up well the world's taking
care of them right now
Kumiko heard that theory is that like
remember what everyone got sick at the
end of December and beginning of January
that it was all those the same symptoms
of like fever flu like dude I was going
to die but it was respiratory like
bronchitis pneumonia it might have been
my daughter had it for like two and a
half weeks yeah we did a little better
and then she got worse again like we
literally sent her back to school yeah
got better
then like literally by Monday it was
back that's exactly what Eversole crazy
so we're good then we already had that
we flushed it out yeah we're good
because we're not old they should rename
this [ __ ] disease like don't be
around old people right now a lot of
people I've heard these stories just of
several different you know flights are
really cheap right now they're like
buying up flights because they're like
I'll gonna [ __ ] if I die I've never seen
the world before and so they're like I
spent my whole life not seeing the world
cause it was so expensive to travel and
now I can afford it
I don't care about dying too bad that
chick it was my dad enough that chick
died couldn't afford the pump avoid
movies they like try to be tearjerkers
it's only offered like the open know
doesn't matter then there's a talking
ostrich and all kinds of yeah The Lion
King trick me I was like never again
similar when father died because I'm a
possum was like the only father figure I
had in my life baby's mom was like a
mother do you see Bambi weeks I never
watch that it's girl fellas pretty hot
too yeah yes I mean you know for lions
action [ __ ] me and I that's I don't want
to see the other like relive what I was
like but animals can't make facial
features the way cartoons can be done
how come like all the animals talk in
Lion King but then Aladdin like the Raja
does not talk I'm like what because
humans are in that movie it's a
different world
Oh bust your bubble I was like hi Raj
[Laughter]
what about Jungle Book do the animals
and the humans talk to each other
nah oh yeah no Tarzan lived there he was
able to translate for the you're saying
he's got monkey no I know but Tarzan was
in the same junk yeah it wasn't
translated for yeah he taught the animal
to listen it's jungle books in India
right
what is it Jungle Book in India oh just
one great jungle know the different
jungles no cuz wait where is he really
the Amazon is it yeah they don't say he
looks more Brazilian
alright like this is just American but
yeah white guy my wait show comedy can
no yeah that's what they're all Indian
names okay so yeah so maybe they all
worried and they're both both Tarzan
Tarzan is white pal
okay you wanna catch somebody else's
stars that black is he's sorry piss me
off because he's cuz he [ __ ] surfs on
the trees he had to be white surf and
skateboard on to you did you forget
no no tons of black people in London
he's doing Ollie's on logs and [ __ ] I
mean yes what are those Spaniards that
like look like they're white but then
you talk to them and they're like oh
[ __ ] you're Spain Spaniard oh maybe
knows what I do like is when I go out
into the normal world people aren't
freaking out the way that they are
online that's true which is pretty cool
you know the supermarket like I feel
like I'm gonna get into a fight or like
I'm gonna like do people they're so nice
yeah
my hands but everyone's just so that's
what I'm saying no we gotta get out
together mentality yeah I gotta get out
there as sues the - suits well it's not
like you have to get out I mean I mean
social distancing for a reason practice
social distancing be responsible but I
don't believe in needing to stay cooped
up and going crazy
I've been going on locks that's good
yeah like around other people no person
comes at me like they cross the street
or I cross the street like we like mmm
that has been weird and also like moved
like going in places people clearly
don't touch things now and they have to
make it announced that they're not
touching something which is oh I know I
went to the ATM and everyone that was
walking in there really the wipes wid me
like wife's I got like surgical gloves
you can wear gloves yeah I went to a
Starbucks drive-through and then when
they gave me my credit card back this
guy literally grabbed like the father's
like this like people really aren't
trying to touch each other he's like he
just wears gloves and you've been such a
good mood he was like hello how are you
doing today I was like wow people are
really nice on the outside in real life
they know you know who needs all the
credit this hello like the Health
Service deserves all the accolades right
now because I anytime there's a crisis
or like a scare like an attack or terror
attack some like that we always give it
to like the first responders mainly the
cops in the fire department but right
now the health services are doing that
damn big grocery store workers man
that's a killer
a new mother like it one I have my my
niece is like six months and my nephew
is like a year as some change and she
has to go to work everyday like they
don't she was part time they increased
her little either everyday like she's
terrified to bring us up the home to the
kids
she has to be there because people are
in me and like we don't think about that
because we're in a completely different
world but like man that's all - all you
guys they're all right in the health
field
thank you some man hats off to the gun
store owners I gotta say I was not
kidding I was in John 4 there's a line
of people going out the [ __ ] door
going down the street and [ __ ] and I
finally get in there for three hours
waiting Ram and I go up to the guy and
he's got gloves on and he's my knee
because you have to have an idea to buy
ammo and [ __ ] people don't [ __ ] down
the [ __ ] but you do you do okay so so
then he's got gloves on any and I put my
ID on the counter right and it's a glass
countertop and he's got gloves he's like
[Laughter]
slowly
[Music]
[Music]
you